american politicians have come up with
some pretty great acronyms over the
years there is of course the uniting and
strengthening america by providing
appropriate tools required to intercept
and obstruct terrorism act of 2001 also
known as
the patriot act the usa patriot act
there is the uniting and strengthening
america by fulfilling rights and
ensuring effective discipline over
monitoring act of 2015
or the
usa freedom act boy that's a good
acronym
but i think that florida governor ron
desantis may have just come up with the
best one yet
a new piece of legislation for the
upcoming legislative session called stop
wrongs against our kids and employees
act the stop woke act and it's something
that
the stop woke act an excellent acronym
and an even more excellent piece of
legislation i'm michael knowles just the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from jesse riley who
says i don't think we're giving jesse
enough credit for giving black people
the roles typically played by white men
you make such a great point jesse that's
true we need more diversity in hollywood
the oscars are too white
and that's all all jesse was doing was
diversifying
fictional roles fictional characters
that's what he was doing and that's
great stuff when you want to protect
yourself whether you're on the street at
night or really in your digital life
it's probably much more important i'd
recommend you check out lifelock this
christmas season of giving is also a
season of taking for cyber criminals
looking to cash in some tips to help you
stay safe while holiday shopping include
only visiting secure sites and apps from
retailers you trust using a vpn instead
of public wi-fi creating strong
passwords and checking your bank and
credit accounts for fraud every day we
put our information at risk on the
internet in an instant a cyber criminal
could steal what's yours sometimes even
harm your finances your credit or your
good reputation good thing there's
lifelock
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats such as your social
security number for sale on the dark web
if they detect your information has
potentially been compromised they will
send you an alert you have access to a
dedicated restoration specialist if you
become a victim no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but
you can help protect what's yours with
lifelock by norton join now save up to
25 percent off your first year by going
to lifelock.com knowles k w l e s that
is lifelock.com slash knowles for 25 off
i totally love the stop woke act i don't
only love it because of how great the
acronym is that the acronym is
magnificent i love it because of what
the law does governor desantis tell us
what it does
and this will do a number of things that
are very important one it will put into
statute uh the department of education's
prohibition on crt in k-12 schools no
taxpayer dollars should be used to teach
our kids to hate our country or to hate
each other
and and that's important and that's all
well and good but i think what we've
seen recently is you can legislate
things like parents bill of rights you
can have certain things and sometimes
the school districts don't always follow
it and so we are going to be including
in this legislation
giving parents a private right of action
to be able to enforce the prohibition on
crt and they get to recover attorneys
fees
when they prevail which is very
important
[Applause]
this is
really good stuff
this is a great use by conservatives of
the government to save our culture he
says it right there he says the
legislation has to have teeth it's one
thing to pass it but how are you going
to enforce it well one way you're going
to enforce it is a
allowing a private right of action for
these parents to go after the schools
this is just sort of thing that you saw
in the texas pro-life law where you are
empowering citizens to sue the
abortionists so there's a mechanism in
there to actually hold these people
accountable we know that the teachers
because of the teacher unions are
unaccountable
there are plenty of good teachers out
there and there are a lot of really bad
teachers out there
and you can't really discriminate
between the two because the teacher
unions are so strong they're going to do
whatever they want we know that
administrations are not really held to
account all that often in in the school
districts and so here's one way we can
do it the parents can actually take
legal action here for the stop
woke
act
i suspect
the squishy people
i suspect maybe some of the libertarians
are not going to like this very much
because
this is imposing limits on academic
freedom and the freedom of teachers and
it's limiting things in the classroom
yeah right that's what that's what you
have to do that's what you have to do
that's the only way
that you can have a coherent culture
academic i've said it before i wrote a
book about this called speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now great book to put in a
christmas stocking
the libs used the nonsensical concept of
academic freedom the hoax in william f
buckley jr's words of academic freedom
to cram in all of their insane ideas
into the curriculum and when they put in
all of their crazy ideas that
necessarily crowded out all of the other
ideas the good conservative normal true
ideas and contradicted them in many
cases so what we need to do if we want
to be able to take that back if we want
to be able to take back education which
means if we want to be able to take back
the next generations of americans we
have got to push out all the crazy
left-wing ideas
and
the stop woke act is a great way to do
it if you don't like the stop woke act
boy howdy you are not going to like the
other law that is being proposed in
florida
which is a bill to require sports teams
to sing the national anthem before
sporting events
oh
speaking of some of the good uses of big
government this is a great one new bill
filed uh
by state representative uh tommy gregory
he's a sarasota area republican lawmaker
this would require profession not all
sports teams not necessarily high school
or college but professional sports teams
to play the national anthem before home
games in order to receive government
funding
this legislation follows a similar bill
in texas that came up after
that jerk
who runs the dallas mavericks stopped
playing the national anthem before their
games
really good stuff so it's not it's not
as knuckle dragging and authoritarian
and right-wing as people are going to
say
it's not saying that you're going to go
to jail if you don't play the national
anthem but saying if you want to receive
government money then you need to stand
up for the flag and you need to support
our star spangled banner in our national
anthem
if you're going to be a professional
sports team you're already getting a ton
of tax perks anyway you are
affiliated with the state are
sports just like all games throughout
all history in in governments
have been a patriotic thing and so now
they've been turned against patriotism
because the left has
abused concepts such as free speech and
free expression and taken them to insane
extremes to undermine the the state
itself so we're gonna go in there and
take that back
this is great stuff
one of the arguments from the squishes
and maybe some libertarians is that this
is tyrannical if peop if if a sports
team doesn't want to
stand up and play the national anthem
then they shouldn't be forced to
the law merely has to enable people to
do whatever they want right the law
needs to respect the individual choices
that's that's not exactly true
okay first of all
law
by its very nature applies to everybody
not just to the individual whims of
individual people
so no that obviously the law is an
imposition to some degree and while we
in
recent years come to think of the law as
merely just reflecting our own will
right we we the people have a will and
then we
push that
will through legislation and then the
law reflects that it goes the other way
as well and i think we need to recognize
this the law does not just react to what
we want
the law also instructs and informs what
we want
statesmen throughout all of history
everywhere in the world have known
this that
for instance some people might want to
do drugs but the law has a prohibition
against drugs and it discourages the use
of drugs and then it creates perhaps
taboos around the use of drugs and then
people do
fewer drugs less often these rules have
weakened in recent years because people
have changed the law and the law doesn't
merely reflect cultural changes but the
law pushes cultural changes as well
before
the gay marriage decision from the
supreme court before obergefell
the culture had a far
less
accepting view of the idea that marriage
means something totally different than
it had always meant now because of that
change in the law people have a very
different view
i'm not even i don't for the moment even
care to talk about gay marriage or drugs
or whatever i'm just pointing out the
fact that the law can affect the way
people think about things and so i think
we ought to use the law and the
government for good stuff if they're
gonna if the libs are gonna use the law
in the government to attack our country
and take away patriotism i think we
should use it to instill patriotism if
the libs are going to use the coercive
education system to teach people radical
crazy gender theory and terrible racial
ideologies we should use it
for the opposite because that's a good
thing well what's the difference between
the right and the left if we're both
willing to use the law and we're both
willing to use the education system the
difference is the substance what are we
teaching what laws are we imposing what
are we standing for for the national
anthem or are we disrespecting the
national anthem those are different
things even if the law is impelling you
to do something in both cases
now
a great use of big government
right i know this is going to be all
about how great big government can be
not just because it's what conservatives
oppose is not big government what we
oppose is unlimited arbitrary capricious
government right there's no such thing
as small government in a country of 330
million people where we've got imperial
holdings all the way from guam to puerto
rico okay there's no you're not going to
have some tiny little
uh republican form of government that
where everybody knows each other and we
all go to vote in the forum or something
like that that's not going to happen so
what we want is a limited government
that is not tyrannical and arbitrary and
just ruled by the whims of dr fauci we
want it to be
good government
and so one
the probably the most basic use of big
government
is to stop
crime okay during crime waves it's good
to have big government during
the 1970s and 80s new york was a very
bad place and there was a lot of crime
then giuliani came in and used big
government and lots of cops
to arrest all the criminals and stop
them from committing their crimes and
guess what new york became a much better
place much more flourishing uh much more
conducive to human flourishing and
much more conservative allowed people to
sleep easy at night kind of like my
pillow you know how much i love my
pillow i love my pillow
in part because of the great politics of
my pillow and because they support good
conservative patriotic causes but i've
mentioned before i'd probably buy from
my pillow if it was run by the taliban
they just make a great product okay and
my pillow wants to give back to our
listeners you can get great discounts on
all my pillow products if you go to
mypillow.com right now click on the
radio listeners specials get deep
discounts on my pillow mattress toppers
towels and so much more for example my
pillow is offering a buy one get one
offer on giza sheets these are top
quality sheets that you will love
all my pillow products come with a
60-day money-back guarantee and a
10-year warranty there's no risk
whatsoever
head on over right now i love my pillow
and i love in particular i love the
pillow you know i love all their
products but pillow it's the greatest
pillow i've ever used go to mypillar.com
click on the radio listener specials for
the buy one get one free offer on the
giza sheets and use promo code daily
wire at checkout or call
800-651-1148 you'll also get discounts
on all those my pillow products the
pillow the slippers the mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets that's
mypillow.com enter code dailywire or
1-800-651-1148 tell them dailywire sent
you
1-800-651-1148 the deals won't last
forever so call now so there's a major
crime wave going on right now all over
the united states i guess you could say
it's been going on for over a year now
because left-wing activists and peaceful
protesters and demonstrators decided to
burn the country down from sea to shiny
sea
but you're seeing this now without even
the facade or pretense of activism
you're just seeing gangs of criminals go
into walgreens and cvs and just steal
tons and tons of stuff break into
jewelry stores it's being filmed
sometimes it's happening in broad
daylight and the cops aren't doing
anything about it i don't blame them the
politicians won't let the cops do
anything about it and if the cops do
anything and and it it contradicts some
racial narrative or it falls into a
certain narrative category on the left
then the cops could have their lives
completely ruined
as these left-wing lawmakers are calling
for the police departments to be
defunded and for prisons to be abolished
so i don't really blame the cops here
but what are we going to do about it
well
nancy pelosi was just asked about this
and she uh
basically just shrugged her shoulders
what do you think about some of this
crime specifically in san francisco uh
smashing grabs and also generally is
there some sort of a federal response
you know we passed crime bills here
before there's something looking at some
of these problems well it is it's it's
absolutely outrageous you know obviously
it cannot continue
but the fact is that there is an
attitude of uh
lawlessness in our country that springs
from i don't know where
maybe you do
and we cannot have that lawlessness
become the norm
there's an attitude of lawlessness but
who knows where it comes from
says nancy pelosi one of the leaders of
the democratic party that has been
saying for years now
that we need to abolish the police that
we need to defund the police and in
in
their defense and sort of in their
defense
the logic of their argument is that
america is an evil place
right there's there's the reason that
they're saying we need to defund the
place and empty out all the prisons
is
not even because they think that there's
no such thing as justice or justice is
not a worthwhile goal or virtue they're
saying that america is unjust
intrinsically it'll always be unjust
because it's white supremacist and
racist and whatever nonsense they spout
so because of that the american system
of law is necessarily evil and unjust
and therefore we've got to get rid of it
i don't think i'm being hyperbolic when
i say that
the cause of the lawlessness in america
is entirely the fault of the left
they they are openly calling for
lawlessness you even see it in in the
way they approach the constitution
right their interpretive principle for
the constitution is that america's evil
and terrible and unjust and all our laws
are terrible and it's based on white
supremacists and blah blah blah blah
blah and therefore we need to just
rewrite the constitution from the bench
and yeah there's no right to an abortion
in the constitution but there should be
so we're just going to put it in there
what are you going to do about it
that that is lawlessness
and so it is no surprise
when criminals go out on the streets and
then the cherry on top of that sunday is
that when all of these thugs went out on
the streets and started burning and
stealing and looting and killing
last year
these people these elected democrats
actively encouraged that
they
they donated to the bail funds for these
people kamala harris donated to the bail
funds for these people
or posted the link and encouraged other
people to donate staffers for joe biden
did the same thing
so that's where
that's where the lawlessness comes from
now speaking of crime
the
the left
does not want to talk about the smashing
grabs aoc you'll remember
wouldn't even go so far as pelosi to
acknowledge it
aoc said oh it's not happening
don't believe your lying eyes don't
believe the retail associations don't
believe walgreens
so pelosi will at least acknowledge it
but the democrats want to talk about a
far worse crime than you know the
zillions of dollars being stolen and the
arson and the looting and the killing
and all that
the libs want to talk about
january 6th here is james carville very
influential and prominent democrat
strategist describing the massive
criminal act of january 6th
it was a massive criminal act the people
who penetrated that capital criminals
the people that helped him penetrate the
capital are criminals you're a lawyer
you know this if i drive the getaway car
or i case the place out i'm just as
guilty as the trigger man all right
that's that that's the way the law
operates
and they're gonna find that members of
congress were aiding the betting this
that trump was behind it major people in
the administration were behind it and we
have to remember this is a massive
criminal attack and just running an
assault
on the temple of democracy or whatever
we say these were criminals in that
in that building and these were people
on fox who were aiding and abetting
criminality that's not a good thing not
not in a nation of laws
and i hope that they stay very very
aggressive and expose these criminals
and the people that supported them to
the very extent that they possibly can
man these democrats they get real tough
on crime when you're talking about the
horn guy dancing around the capitol
rotunda they get really tough on crime
when some midwestern dad cracks a coors
light and puts his thumb up in front of
a picture
in the capitol
they get really they are ready to send
you to gitmo they're probably going to
bring back the death penalty in a lot of
their states when you're talking about
that florida guy who was smiling with
nancy pelosi's lectern as he'd walked
out of the capitol with it
not so tough when it comes to actual
crime
right and not so tough when it comes to
actual looting and robbing and killing
and that because this is friend enemy
politics right this is
the blm people are my friends the antifa
people are my friends so i'm just not
going to prosecute them and the horn guy
is my enemy and so i am going to pretend
that this guy
is the gravest threat to the united
states ever that we've ever faced
and there's no
objective standard here it's just
i like my friends i hate my enemies
that's what they're talking about and
corville goes pretty far he doesn't just
say that the the eccentric people at the
capitol who didn't who didn't kill
people who didn't kill cops who didn't
do any of the things that the libs say
that they did
he's saying it wasn't just them who were
the terrible criminals it's trump trump
was behind it we got him now there's
gonna stay tuned buckle up buckaroo
there is really serious stuff coming out
of the january 6th commission
how
stupid do they think we are
very stupid i guess
stupid they think we are
how many times are they going to pull
this
oh just you wait
we've got a russia investigation trump
is behind a massive crime oh just you
wait we're gonna get him we're gonna get
him
what happened with that they didn't get
him
oh but we forget russia for a second now
ukraine
you know russia's enemy we got well he
was actually yeah maybe he wasn't
colluding with the russians but he's
colluding with the ukrainians yeah we
got him massive crime we're going to and
we're going to get him
what's going to and what happened with
that
ah they didn't get him on that oh
oh it's mueller time baby nope no that
that didn't well we're gonna the
southern district is gonna get him is
that okay is that and the
investigation and we're gonna and now so
now it's january 6. and and then
carville goes out
this is the most implausible of all he
goes well now you had you had fox news
fog news and drum yeah it's not it's not
a great james carville impression
when they were doing well wrongdoing
now what wrong doing the texts that came
out which by the way were were doctored
we recently learned
the texts that came out from fox news
hosts and
conservatives texting the white house
and don jr even texting the white house
texting mark meadows the white house
chief of staff and saying hey this is
bad stop this have trump go out there
and speak they
if anything they show that the prominent
conservatives were discouraging
any sort of violence at the capitol
right they weren't saying yeah go get
them they were saying no get the
president out there to go tell people to
go home and then what what happened
that's exactly what happened trump went
out and said hey stop it go home
totally exonerates everybody
but
they're going to gin it up and gin it up
and then nothing's going to come of it
you know what they're going to
they're just going to do it again
they're going to pick another topic
and do it again another non-traversing
and do it again and it's going to be
mostly democrats leading the charge with
a handful of court jester conservatives
there as well like liz cheney speaking
of january 6th and the january 6th
commission turns out that at least one
of just two nominally republican members
on the january 6 commission is getting a
ton of money
from lib donors liz cheney raked in
about 55 grand
from the same donors who fund the
lincoln project the lincoln project is
this scandal-ridden left-wing operation
by a bunch of disgruntled former
republican operatives who couldn't get
jobs anymore so they started to work for
democrats and then one of them got in
trouble because it turned out he was
grooming young boys for sex
and so so the lincoln project not a very
reputable honorable organization and the
same donors to the lincoln project are
funding liz cheney
a lot of money a billionaire
john pritzker who's given a 100 grant of
lincoln project gave cheney over 21
grand another silicon valley investor
ron conway
top donor to the lincoln project gave
gave liz cheney and her campaign
committees the same amount of money
just for the people who say liz cheney's
actually her voting record is fairly
conservative yeah whatever when push
comes to shove at the crucial moments
she sides
with the other guys this is
friend enemy politics gets right back to
it she's at the where it counts she
sides
with the other guys that's a lot of
money we're talking about man 21 600
that's especially these days with gas
prices so high well if you want to save
a little money at the pump i'd recommend
you check out get upside i am thrilled
to introduce an incredible app that
everyone who buys gas needs to know
about that's get upside do you buy gas
or you like every other american well
then you need get upside my listeners
are making up to 25 cents for every
gallon of gas every time they fill up
actually that's not true that's not
quite true because on your first tank
you can save up to 50 cents per gallon
of gas just download the free get upside
app in the app store or google play
right now use promo code nols get a
bonus 25 cents per gallon on your first
fill up that is up to 50 cents
cashback per gallon
do not pay full price at the pump
anymore get cash back using get upside
just download the app for free use promo
code knowles to get up to 50 cents per
gallon cash back on your first tank
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred dollars
a month in cash back there's no catch
the cash back gets added right to your
account you can cash out any time to
your bank account paypal or an e-gift
card for amazon and other brands
download the free get upside app use
promo code nulls to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cash back on your first tank
that is code know w l e s you know the
daily wire was the first company in the
country to sue the biden administration
for their unconstitutional mandate we're
getting closer to a million signatures
on our do not comply petition every
single day
right now big hospital chains are
dropping vaccine mandates for healthcare
workers because of this kind of pushback
so we're almost at 900 000 signatures so
far we need your help to cross the
finish line right now please sign the
petition at dailywire.com do not comply
then share our petition with all of your
family and friends also excited to
announce a new series exclusively on
daily wire if you've ever wanted to be a
fly on the wall for some ben shapiro
behind the scenes then you're in luck in
the premiere episode jordan peterson
joins ben for coffee while he's visiting
nashville and they talk as if the
cameras are not there take a listen
alrighty so i'm here in nashville with
jordan peterson jordan's spending a lot
of time in nashville in fact i think
jordan may know nashville better than i
do last night you dragged me to robert's
western world and you were like you were
like the the guy of the house like they
all knew you no no luke mccrory was the
guy the house the guitarist playing the
guitar
kelly's heroes they're a deadly band i
will say i feel like i was a little more
dressed for it like i was wearing a
t-shirt and a and a
leather jacket and you were wearing this
yeah
i didn't have my kobe boots i haven't
bought them yet i'll get a cardboard
combo
it was really fun being there with you
oh yeah i know that that was awesome
you're a classically trained violinist i
am nice and and you like the music oh
yeah and i love that stuff i mean if
you're a good musician you're a good
musician yeah
they
sunday special is a lot more formal i
mean i'm coming in with questions and
it's much less of kind of a discussion
between the two of us and it's much more
of kind of just me probing and jordan's
ideas but this is much more like how we
talk normally i mean jordan you called
me we talked on the phone like a month
ago and this was basically the same
conversation right this is how we talk
about different topics but yeah
different topics but i mean like this is
this is how we talk when the cameras
aren't on us people really love being in
on those conversations i yeah no i i
think that the fact that people are
going to kind of get the
the
kind of the fly on the wall view of this
kind of conversation is pretty awesome
so you'll be able to see clips of my
conversation with jordan here at the
coffee shop on youtube but if you want
to see the whole conversation which
really is the way you should see it you
need to head on over to dailywire.com or
check us out on the daily wire app
you'll be able to see the whole thing
there and it's it's pretty fantastic
not only do i want to listen to that
conversation but i want jordan
peterson's suit it's a great so my gosh
that guy has the best suits ben's
conversation with jordan drops tomorrow
it'll only be available at dailywire.com
if you're not a member yet now is the
perfect time to sign up head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe to sign up today
clips of the show will be available on
youtube but make sure to subscribe to
hear the whole thing we'll be right back
with a lot more
just thinking of liz cheney for some
reason liz cheney
brings to mind vladimir putin i don't
maybe it's just because they're both
very deceitful people i don't know but
vladimir putin is a top of mind right
now and in the news because
there is a real chance that tanks are
about to roll in ukraine
i guess that would be another reason is
because you had all of these never
trumper types attacking trump for
colluding with russia then they attack
him for colluding with ukraine but
ukraine and russia might might go to war
and it won't be much of a war if putin
invades ukraine he's just going to take
it
i was talking to senator cruz just a
week or two ago about this he thinks
that tanks could roll into ukraine
starting
maybe beginning of
some sometime in january
why would this happen and what should
the united states response be
this would happen because vladimir putin
has called the collapse of the soviet
union the greatest geopolitical disaster
of the 20th century and there were a lot
of geopolitical disasters in the 20th
century so if he thinks that the
collapse of the evil empire is the
greatest one we should take him
seriously
and and here's his explanation he says
what's the disintegration within the
ussr that's the collapse of historical
russia called the soviet union
we turned into a completely different
country and what had been built up over
a thousand years was largely lost
so this is an interesting take from
putin
because the the traditional take of of
the of russia and the soviet union is
that you had the russian
nation and the russian empire and it had
been built up until the revolution until
the russian revolution when the commies
came in and then they created this
entirely new entity that that destroyed
russian history and executed the family
of the czar and they created the soviet
union but that's not what putin is
describing
putin is saying no the soviet union was
just an extension it was just the next
step of the historic russian nation
and so when you destroy the soviet union
you're actually destroying a thousand
years of russian history so it's putin
is not viewing it as as some communist
ideologue who hates russia's history and
wants to completely change it he's he's
viewing himself it would seem as a new
kind of czar as just an extension of all
the old czars of russia
and so he wants to get that back he
wants to take back the territory that
was lost with the collapse of the soviet
union
now
in 1991 as the soviet union is
collapsing ukraine
votes in a landslide to become an
independent nation now it's a little
complicated because there are still some
people in ukraine who wouldn't mind
being part of russia and there's just
there's an internal political battle
within ukraine
so the
claim against trump for the past what
five years is that trump was colluding
with the russians
and the traditional conservative
response to this is no he's not
colluding with the russians how dare you
say he's colluding with the russians
now i've got a little bit of an out
there kind of suggestion
i've got a kind of out-there left-field
thought when i hear this accusation that
trump is colluding with the russians
namely
should
should we maybe collude with the
russians i don't look don't i don't
please don't yell at me i know this is
i'm a little out there right now
but if you asked me today who is our
number one
geopolitical enemy and threat
is it
russia
or china
who poses the gravest threat to american
power
i'll ask you that what do you think
china right it's not even close
it's not even close china is stealing
our technology they've got it extremely
robust economy they've got a gazillion
people in there they're threatening
united states interests around the world
they've got all of our manufacturing
that's a huge national security threat
they own our debt they're buying up a
lot of our lives they're a huge threat
so
when when the soviet union was the big
threat during the cold war
what did the united states do china a
growing power
soviet union evil empire our number one
enemy in the world what did we do we
cozied up to china
we cozied up to china
to box in the soviet union it was it was
a cold war strategy so i guess my
question now is
if china is the grave threat why would
we also want to why would we want to
wage a two-front war against china and
russia would it not be better i'm not
saying we need to you know put out the
welcome mat and let the russians roll
into whatever country they want but but
i am suggesting
wouldn't it be better
to have better relations with russia as
we are heating up our tensions with
china it seems to me
that we would and that's not what we're
doing what we're doing is actually
pushing china and russia closer together
moscow
is is beijing's largest arms supplier
they provide 70
of china's arms imports between 2014 and
2018. relations between moscow and
russia are at a quote unprecedented
unprecedentedly high level according to
vladimir putin
china is a friendly nation he says it
has not declared us an enemy as the
united states has done
china and russia are united like a
mountain and our friendship is
unbreakable says the foreign ministry
spokesman xiao li jian in china
so this is obviously what putin wants
putin wants a super tight relationship
with china that's obviously what china
wants but what so why do we want that
though why are we pushing them
together there are a lot of wedges here
that we could have we could
use trade
the trade
between china and russia is extremely
imbalanced we could use china
encroaching on some of russia's economic
territory buying up resources in russia
just like they're buying up resources in
the united states we could use it but i
just
it seems to me that the thinking of the
1980s is not necessarily going to work
in 2020 and a lot of the problems on the
right are because we don't recognize
that while principles and values remain
the same circumstances change
and so my my humble suggestion i just
look did you see vladimir putin built
this beautiful cathedral
in russia this gorgeous beautiful
beautiful art architecture it wasn't
merely aping the past it was it was
taking the best of the past and kind of
adding some modern elements this
beautiful orthodox cathedral
and then you look at what the western
secularists are doing and they want to
turn notre dame into some fruity
disneyland
maybe all i'm saying is maybe we should
consider to some degree
colluding with the russians maybe that's
not
not the worst thing in the world because
whatever strategy we're pursuing now is
not working
and speaking of bad strategies
it's a story out of oregon a group of
oregon high school and middle middle
school students
these young girls
decided that they were going to protest
sexualization
by taking off their clothes at school
and just wearing their bras
this is a real story it's not not the
onion it's not the babylon bee
at southridge high school in beaverton
school district students came to school
in lace bras that revealed
everything did not leave very much to
the imagination lingerie bottoms
according to one parent
and uh they did this they wrote actually
some protest slogans on their bodies and
some of their clothing that
that said rape culture or educate your
boys or my body
or my clothing choice my body my
clothing choice
i don't know what
young man at this high school came up
with this idea but he is a genius he is
a devilish clever man to convince the
women that they were going to protest
sexualization
by taking all their clothes off and
parading around for the boys that's
that is like protesting obesity by
eating a bunch of donuts that is like
protesting lung disease by just
slurping up cigarettes not just chain
smoking non-stop
but this there is a kind of
logic to it just like there's a kind of
logic to defund the police and abolish
prisons if you think america is
hopelessly unjust then obviously you got
to dismantle the system of laws well
it's the same thing here
this is the logical consequence of this
liberal conception of
of the individual being able to do
whatever the individual wants based
purely on the individual's will
if i want to be a woman then i really am
a woman and my will will transform
reality
if i want to
pursue whatever desire i want then i can
do that and you have no right to stop me
from doing that
well this is the logical conclusion of
that
the girls are saying
i don't want
boys to look on me with lust
okay and i don't i don't want to have to
watch where i walk at night i don't i
don't want to have to worry about
walking down a dark alley wearing a
miniskirt in the middle of the night in
the bad section of town i shouldn't have
to worry about that i'm the victim stop
victim blaming me just teach boys not to
rape
just teach boys not to look lustfully on
women well sure yeah there are laws
against rape right there of course
that's good we like that the law is an
instructor the law is but
you will never
never
stop boys
from getting a thrill out of seeing
naked ladies you're j it just can't
happen no matter how much you desire
that no matter how intransigent you are
and and
and
obstinate you are about your rights and
your will
you will never convince boys not to
think that naked ladies are cute and hot
you will it can't happen well just teach
boys not no you're what you are doing
is denying reality and making the
problem worse
if you are protesting sexualization by
prancing around in your bras
you are not go it just won't help you're
making when we deny reality we make
problems worse
though you do wonder with these high
school sort of protests how much of it
is just
you know the more things change the more
things remain the same how much of this
is just
the girls putting on a show for the boys
and how much of this is the boys
you know trying to flirt with the girls
you wonder these things whatever it is
it's not an effective political protest
whatever whatever dudes whatever creepy
dudes convince the girls to do this stop
it that's not that's not nice to do
speaking of creepy dudes
i've already i just read the creepiest
opinion column i have ever read in my
whole life and i read a lot of op-eds
headline men like me
benefit from safe abortion access
this is by kavan
kayvon shroff he is
a senior advisor to the institute for
education
which is some
dc ngo
he's got degrees i think from pretty
fancy schools
kavon shroff and he says that he
a man who has promiscuous sex with women
that he doesn't care very much about and
doesn't want to be with
he benefits from abortion quote men like
me
have long been the direct beneficiaries
of safe abortion access most of the
women i've had sex with were also
students like me also progressive and
also not at a point in their lives where
they were looking for ready to have
children i try to share responsibility
for birth control and if a woman tells
me she's on it i also trust that oh he's
isn't he he's so progressive believe all
women right
if she got pregnant however
though entirely her decision i assume we
would both want the same thing an
abortion in longer-term relationships
we've had explicit discussions about
this so he'll sit down if he's if he
sleeps with a woman and he you know
maybe he doesn't really like her like he
doesn't want to marry her or anything
but he likes her well enough to keep
sleeping with her for at least some
period of time he's going to sit her
down and say hey
hey missy don't you get any ideas in
your head
if
there is a product of our fake love the
love that i'm performing even though i
don't actually feel any love for you
if there is any product namely a new
beautiful human being that is a little
bit from me and a little bit from you
we're gonna kill that thing right and
we're and if not i refuse to keep having
casual sex with you for some
undetermined amount of time
he says what if i got a woman pregnant
what if she didn't want to continue the
pregnancy but could not get an abortion
would we try to stay together even if it
wasn't a fit hey buster pretty sure it
was a fit okay i'm pretty sure that's
kind of
the issue in the first place right but
it was but it's not a it's a fit
physically but it's not i don't actually
like her soul or her spirit or her mind
i don't like it's not a fit would we
stay together
how would i provide for the child would
i have to get a job oh god i want to get
a job
what kind of custody or visitation
rights would i get if we weren't
together oh god that'd be would i want
that would i have to i'd have to see the
kid and work and then pay for the kid oh
would adoption really be a consideration
as justice amy coney barrett recently
glibly suggested
i love that this this guy
is accusing someone else of being glib
this guy
who thinks it's
unjust and insane not to let him kill
his children with all the women that
he's using he's suggesting that a
supreme court justice with adopted
children is being glib about adoption if
so
would the child face an abusive welfare
system when it paused there no the child
wouldn't because for every infant put up
for adoption in the united states for
every newborn baby there are an
estimated 36 couples trying to adopt
that baby there is no the children who
end up in the foster care system or the
well government system are
there obviously that's a terrible system
we should reform it as best we can
but it's not little babies being put up
for
for those systems
it's older kids being taken out of bad
homes and those are harder to adopt
terms of the little babies there is no
shortage
of adoptive parents
the questions
and worries abound
so i read this i read this creepy column
by creepy kevin shroff
and i see just a lot of red flags
not for me what do i care i don't have
any intention of sleeping with mr shroff
but for all these other women if if it's
him or if it's some other dude who's
really really into abortion
run run for your life lady let there be
a lady-shaped hole in the wall where you
run away from this guy
what do you get out of this
the one thing you could say you get out
of this is some pleasure from sex
but does anyone if we're all being
really really honest about reality and
we're not buying into crazy left-wing
ideologies does anyone really believe
that women get the same sort of pleasure
from sex that men do
i
i don't really buy that i don't and i
don't think women if they're being
honest with themselves really buy that
either
this is talk about tricks that dudes
play on
chicks
i think all of feminism is basically
just a trick that dudes played on chicks
right oh yeah you know it would be
really you know it would be a really
effective political protest if you took
all your clothes off and danced around
in front of me that would be really that
would be totally free the nipple
remember that movement there was the
free the nipple movement to try to have
more obscene imagery on on social media
oh yeah that would be empowering if you
got naked and jiggled in front of me
yeah that would be really empowering and
you know what else would be really
empowering if you slept with me without
asking anything of me whatsoever and not
requiring me to be accountable or
responsible to you at all that would be
you would be so man that'd make you so
strong
no so we're doing that that's cool
that's good that works uh no
what do women get out of that what do
women get out of creepy dudes like kaven
shroff nothing you get nothing you just
get used and then he's gonna move on and
if he does knock you up he's going to
make you kill that kid or he's going to
really put a lot of pressure on you to
kill your kid and then he's going to
leave you and then there's going to be
another cabin raw who comes along and
does the same thing
and then you're going to do that and
probably you're going to be in you're in
some liberal social circles and you're
gonna be in some major metropolitan area
and like a hundred guys are gonna do
that and then guys aren't gonna like you
anymore because they're gonna go for
some younger girl that they convinced to
dance around naked for them
and you are gonna be left
high and dry lady don't do it don't fall
for these guys goodness gracious
i'm on a mission of mercy here come on
what are you doing speaking of abortion
who gets abortions
who gets abortions asks the new york
times
it's a big piece this is a big
do not overturn roe versus wade
activist piece in the new york times
they say the typical patient here we go
typical patient is already a mother is
in her late 20s
attended some college but doesn't have a
degree
has a low income
has a low income i'm gonna underline
that one so low income
is unmarried
is in her first six weeks of pregnancy
is having her first abortion lives in a
blue state
that's the and so
come on
even you pro-lifers need to admit we
need abortion right
we need abortion because abortion um
mostly just kills poor people
look they're she's poor
you what you want more poor babies then
they're going to be all you know they're
going to be all like wanting your money
and they're going to be all like you
know
poor and it's going to be icky and you
have to walk by them on the street and
and she's unmarried so you might need to
pay more in taxes
or really i don't usually the welfare
systems the the foster care system is so
terrible the government run
uh child care systems are so terrible
maybe you'd have to you have to give
more to charity
oh that's no good
and look she's not she doesn't even have
a college degree she's not even educated
in the way that the liberal
establishment wants her to be so she's
what what the new york times is saying
is that the women who get abortions
are
uh poor
and dumb
and
we don't want them to have kids
right that's what's underlying all of
this
pretty
pretty ghastly take i'm gonna go out
there i'm going to and again this is
going to be kind of wacky and crazy and
out of left field i don't think that we
should kill all the poor people
i don't think that we should kill all
the people who are below a certain iq or
a certain level of educational
attainment especially the especially the
latter good grief
as though as though a college degree
implied really much of anything these
days with the collapse of our
educational system but i don't think we
should kill dumb people either and i
don't think we should kill people based
on their race and i don't think we
should kill people based on their
geography and i just don't
i just don't think we should kill
innocent people
but this is how they think this this is
how they think which is ghastly and this
is how they think that we think
which is pretty pretty sad as well
just a little final
point on this dr oz dr oz is tv host
he's running for senate as a republican
in pennsylvania now
but
there was a video that came out of him
uh making fun of the pro-life movement
and pro-life people this was some time
ago and so now he's being grilled about
this
on
fox news he refuses to really give an
answer on when he think life thinks life
begins
what is your position as both a doctor
and a senatorial candidate on when life
begins when should we draw the line when
abortion is is legal
as a doctor i appreciate the sanctity of
life and for that reason i'm strongly
pro-life with the three exceptions i've
mentioned that's how i would vote
and when does that life begin
you know again if i'm pro-life then it's
a decision that comes back to the
sanctity of when you think life does
begin and i believe it begins when
you're in the mother's womb
when you're in the mother's womb but
that that carries you all the way up to
nine months of pregnancy
no of course that life's already started
when you're in your mother's womb but
it's a rat hole to get trapped in the
different ways of talking about you we
need as a nation to make sure the
constitution is appropriately followed
and people like me and you may be in the
same camp who are pro-life have our
feelings respected and this is something
that should not be taken away from us by
judiciary legislating from the bench
yeah but that's also something that's
going to have to be legislated and that
answer is going to have to be given
specifically
good on this guy this interviewer is
doing a great job here that is some weak
sauce from dr oz how hard is it to say
conception
how hard is it this is
this is the simplest answer this is the
most tried and true answer this is the
true by definition answer when does life
begin it begins at conception at the
conception of life uh it begins you know
uh when does life begin it begins you
know when we decide when we need to have
people make their decision about and it
comes to the question of when does life
begin yeah buddy that's what i'm asking
you what's it when does it begin it
begins and it's a clever answer he says
it begins when you're in the mother's
womb
well yeah we all we all agree with that
even the most radical pro-abortion
people
i guess with maybe a couple of
exceptions believe that life begins you
know at least by the day before birth
when you're in the mother's womb so when
though when when does it be well you
know in it
uh it's already begun it you know okay
well
so say so just say it
say consent but he can't say it
even john mccain would say it john
mccain who is
you know a little on the squishier side
when it comes to conservatism
john mccain said it during his
presidential race he said i believe life
begins a conception why is it so hard
for dr oz maybe because dr oz
doesn't really believe it
we are in a moment right now where we
are moving the overton window where we
are aggressive where conservatives are
actually making substantial wins we're
stopping woke we're doing this stop woke
act we're making big wins don't settle
for squishes folks i'm michael knowles
this is michael and i'll shall see you
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show